[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and the
former government special adviser anita
bratting they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
well according to the times boris
johnson plans to recruit ministerial
colleagues who may have fallen out of
the number 10 inner circle but who he
sees as allies to defend him as
questions over his leadership continue
the guardian reports that the prime
minister is being encouraged to hand
over all evidence in relation to parties
at downing street during lockdown as
opposed to considering the mata closed
after the release of sugray's report
the eye understands nhs bosses are
considering reversing course on making
covid vaccines compulsory for their
staff amid fears 70 000 of them could
quit
the express has word of what it calls a
wonder pill which purports to treat both
kobed and the flu
the male pleads with the government to
scrap a planned national insurance hike
in an attempt to tackle the increasing
cost of living
according to the telegraph the attorney
general suella braverman is to seek an
injunction to rent the bbc reporting the
identity of an alleged spy
the financial times hears that netflix
has lost 48 billion dollars of its
market value in a single day after
projections showed its growth in
subscribers slowing down
and the mirror pays tribute to the
singer meatloaf who the paper says died
of covid
a reminder that by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by susan
bonnie base susan i'm not sure that she
is a susan susie boniface and anita
wetting are you a susan
don't ask my no one ever calls me that
i'm a susie and my mother will insist it
deathbed
welcome to you both susie and anita
let's start with the
times um
and this story about uh the prime
minister boris johnson surrounding
himself with allies that um
really he feels supported by so sort of
surrounding himself with a massive
comfort blanket is that going to help
anita
well i think it's very clear the prime
minister should and is circling the
wagons on this it's incredibly important
that there is a shift a monumental shift
in the operation following what many
perceived to be some own goals from
number 10 in the past um couple of weeks
and months and so this story reports
that the that boris johnson is
attempting to persuade for instance
eddie lister a former
chief of staff to come back into the
operation um linton crosby the so-called
wonderkind who delivered conservative
majorities for david cameron and for
boris johnson so um and dan rosenfeld
the current chief of staff possibly
saying that he might need to fall on his
sword um so it definitely is
one of those classic behind the scenes
specimens of stories that speculates
that johnson is going to materially and
significantly shape up shake up his team
and susie is this what his problem has
been he's not been surrounded by the
right people um his attempts to to do
that now is that going to make any
difference
well
the most interesting bit of this story
to me is in the second column uh where
steve swinton reports that martin
reynolds who is the
sort of the assistant the aide coming
with the exact job title now private
sector i think
that's right private secretary who
actually organized the uh byob party on
an email that's been sort of the biggest
scandal out of the whole of the many
parties
there's revelation here that he's
actually flipped in terminology used by
the fbi when dealing with the mafia and
he started talking candidly in quotes to
sue gray
and this may well have been influenced
one might think by briefings all last
week saying that martin reynolds was
going to get the bullet
so
he's actually he's talking quite happily
and he's telling her everything now that
does seem according to this article to
have changed the attitude a bit in
within number 10 they do think now
according to the very first paragraph
here that a vote of no confidence is
more likely than not that when sue
grey's report come out there is going to
be enough letters and that there will be
a vote and that's what boris johnson is
circling the wagons for in order to try
to win because that will require a vote
of 181 mps and so he's hoping to try and
get that number behind him to win that
eventual vote and how he's doing that is
he's using grant shaps um because during
his leadership bid grant shaps had a
spreadsheet i've got a spreadsheet it's
full of parties at the moment but grant
shaps had a spreadsheet during the
leadership campaign in 2019 in which he
listed all the mps and where they were
and whether they're supporting boris or
not so he's brought grant and his
spreadsheet is xl back in
unfortunately now he is prime minister
boris johnson's already got a whips
operation that are doing exactly that
kind of thing so now he's got a whips
operation which as we all know is
dysfunctional and grant shouts into his
spreadsheet and they're both trying to
do the same thing at the same time while
boris johnson is desperately trying to
cycle backwards into where he was in
2019. meanwhile
he seems to have been quite seriously
weakened because other papers are
reporting you know that he's giving in
giving away on this and the other and
he's going to do policies here and agree
to what various backbenchers want
and linton crosby the the wunderkind
anita was talking about there who helped
boris johnson get elected back in 2019
has been asked to rejoin them but isn't
sure if he should because he doesn't
know if he can trust boris johnson's
word when boris says he will submit to
what they call general election
discipline which is actually being told
what to do for about six weeks
what he would be
what he would be advised to to do now
let's move into the guardian um anita uh
and this story about having to provide
more evidence surrounding the parties
irrespective of sue gray's investigation
which we hope to hear from next week
yes and this is i think quite obviously
for those of us who watch westminster
quite closely labor and the liberal
democrats rightly trying to get into the
story somewhat so they are the ones that
are kind of leaping on paper speculation
that perhaps the report will not be a
kind of
who did it who done it naming all sorts
of names and there will be some kind of
summary that will be provided for the
public to consume and they're therefore
trying to do the running by arguing that
the report needs to be published in full
it looks like a little premature
um because we don't actually know what's
going to be in the report and i would
say in general that i'm not sure number
10 is being helped by the endless
briefings that we've just been talking
about about who's given what advice and
what might be coming in the report
because ultimately none of us will
really know until it's set out in black
and white in that report uh it does sort
of point to the fact that that uh
they're quite divided at the tories
though doesn't it anita
i mean certainly it's definitely the
most difficult moment in the prime
minister's premiership so far and a
moment of maximum danger like we are in
no doubt that the fact that there is
such considerable speculation about a
leadership challenge almost regardless
of what happens as a result of that
challenge is incredibly damaging to the
prime minister susie do you think it's
premature to call for for more evidence
surrounding the parties regardless of
sue grey's findings to come
oh i agree it's premature but i would
also say it's politically very savvy
because what's going to happen next week
is whenever sugree's report comes out
and she's just a civil servant examining
the the interpretation of the guidance
around the regulations she's not
examining whether the actual rules the
regulations were broken she's looking at
the guidance around it and how the
people around the prime minister
interpreted them so it's very vague to
start with but whenever that report
comes out and whatever it says there are
going to be lots of demands on all sides
for the full background to be published
and so the fact that they're not
intending to do that now and we are
definitely going to get those calls next
week means calling for it now getting in
there early means that next week you
know labor can say we've been demanding
this live demons can say we've been
demanding this for ages you need to deal
with and then they can later when
boris johnson perhaps has to give in
either to the request of his own
backbenchers or the 1922 committee or
himself wants to publish that report
because he believes it exonerates him in
some way he then looks like he's giving
in to the opposition so it's a very
savvy move politically to the eye which
is a quite quite a big story i think the
um massive u-turn that the government is
taking on mandating 70 000 nhs workers
to be vaccinated they are pulling right
back from that within two weeks of the
deadline that they'd set
anita
um definitely this is a huge huge story
and i think in part it's been very clear
that that sajavid this conservative
government did not want to introduce
mandatory vaccinations for nhs staff and
i think it was a finely balanced
decision on the basis of risk risk to
those vulnerable people that need nhs
treatment and
who obviously want to be treated by
people who are vaccinated as a result of
the fact that obviously unvaccinated
people spread the disease much much more
easily um but also disconcern about what
it would do to retention um and so the
eye story splashes on fears over a
potential loss of 70 000 nhs workers
which is an enormous number um at a
moment where pressure on the nhs is only
increasing and so i feel it's a very
finely balanced thing part of the
decision around mandatory vaccinations
was obviously to encourage and really
kind of push people
who work for the nhs into vaccinations
that seems to have worked somewhat but
whether it's going to be enough for the
government to decide to actually roll
back on this idea that's supposed to be
coming in in april of mandatory sackings
essentially if you don't you're not
mandatory mandatory vaccinated it's
quite a big step
uh they just couldn't afford to to lose
70 000 nhs workers could they susie
no of course they couldn't what's not
clear here is whether that is still the
figure that we're looking at there was
some talk about maybe a hundred thousand
or seventy thousand stuff a few uh weeks
months ago when the policy sort of first
came in and we do know that in other
countries where they introduced mandates
like this for public servants for new
york police for example there are lots
of talk about this is going to make
thousands of people leave their jobs and
actually it was a dozen or so and it
wasn't as bad we don't know at the
moment how many of these 70 000 are
frontline medics and they are the ones
that would be most required to um to get
that vaccine there's plenty of other
people of course who work in the nhs and
the vast majority of nhs staff who
consist of millions
have quite happily been vaccinated and
are happy to be boosted and everything
else so this is a minority of nhs staff
we don't know how many of them are
actually going to be affected in the
long run but like anita says the fact
that the government is prepared to say
well we're going to have to delay it a
bit more because not enough of
vaccinated yet is quite a it's quite a
u-turn it's not quite a full doughnut
because they're not saying we're not
going to bring in the vaccine mandate
they just say i'm going to delay it a
bit because of the staff shortages that
we've had over the omicron wave to make
it easier for the nhs to deal with when
it does come in okay susie and anita for
the moment thank you we are going to
take a break but coming up more pressure
on boris johnson to scrap a hike in
taxes more on that next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me susie boniface and anita
blatting uh let's take a look at the
daily mail front page and the story on
the rise in national insurance
contributions um much disagreement with
this hike that's being proposed because
it's going to add to all the woes that
that the the public are experiencing
with the the cost of living rises um
susie take us into this one
yeah so this is one of those things
where you've got a prime minister who's
in a weakened position and there are
people in his party who are unhappy with
this uh policy to start with increasing
national insurance contributions now
events have happened and uh we've got to
cost a living crisis we've got a field
cap coming in april as you said and this
is now looking increasingly unaffordable
the problem is boris johnson really
needs the good headlines from papers
like the mail and the support from his
back benches that getting rid of this
increase would give him he really needs
it unfortunately he's promised billions
of pounds to the nhs they're banking on
it and they've planned for it so if
you're suddenly not going to have this
tax hike what do you do with the nhs and
the nhs after the winter has just had
really really needs the cash
um this is a sign of a of a weakened
prime minister being put on the back
foot by his party saying we want we want
things we want not just the red meat you
want to give us we want what we need and
you need to start complying with our
requests otherwise we're going to take
you out we're going to see more of this
in the weeks to come uh depending on
what surrey's report says of course and
how things go from there but there's
going to be an increasing signs of boris
johnson having to give in to various
different bits of his party and anita
remind us of the uh chancellor's line on
this
well the chance has always been clear
that what he wants to do is cut taxes
but i think the massive challenge that
was presented by the nhs backlog meant
that essentially this this tax hike is
going to deliver 36 billion pounds into
the nhs and eventually into social care
and it felt as though the chances
certainly back in september when this
was announced felt as though he was in
between a rock and a hard place which
was that the nhs did have a kind of
voracious appetite for more funding but
ultimately he felt like if we took the
pain now and increased taxes now that
would eventually lead to bringing down
the backlog and then being able to cut
taxes in the next few years
and that was the strategy i think the
inflation which is not the fault of this
government um which is happening
globally is going to make things an
awful lot tougher before they get better
right we've just got about a minute to
finish off on um adele and her
disappointing her her legions of fans
who've spent
enormous amounts of money to get out to
see in las vegas but it's not going to
happen susie
no she's left until 24 hours before she
opens her las vegas residency uh it's in
most the papers today that's the i think
it's the times there but on the daily
mail they've got two solid pages about a
woman who's worth 150 million pounds
crying because she can't make 500 grand
a night uh as of tomorrow and in fact to
be fair she was crying because she was
going to let her fans down no
yeah don't believe it
two pages about the fans fine two pages
about the millionaires crying
cynic you cynic uh we've run out of time
but uh thank you both for the moment